[Music]
come on come on
uh
you could have just turned it off
okay
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
usual place immediately shrink bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
i needed to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days or
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic knocks faces
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa you're the unidentified source oh
yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit
a big up weight coming your way you have
to launch now did he say gravity wave
trouble
we're underwater guys
uh
that's crazy
what's the plan save the new and save
earth
ray
wait for it
let's go you son
[Music]
everybody hang on i'm gonna get you home
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
[Music]
you